c'était émouvant
difficile de parler de ce que j'ai à
part les bons que voit-on ici j'ai envie
de commencer comme tout le monde
lever la main ce genre jamais vu la mer
je vais faire ça dit ok les trois quarts
de la planète sont couvertes d'où
évidemment ça c'est l'océan
il ya des lacs et des rivières et des
piscines hors terre et on prend pour
acquis
parce que la terre et couvertes d'eau on
prend pour acquis que l'être humain sait
nager mais si on prend une personne
comme ça au hasard puis on l'a pitch
dans l'eau parce que la terre et
couvertes d'eau et ben qu'est ce qui va
arriver si c'est pas nager ça marche ça
faire là il va se noyer
you here il va mettre tes vrais comme ça
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait pour le sortir
de l'eau à barbe en bout et au le puis
jhen bouées et puis s'il est bon il va
s'accrocher et puis va vivre et puis
qu'est-ce qui va faire il va apprendre à
nager pour plus que jamais ça ne
recommence
alors écoutez jacques ferla allusion à
l'océan quand on parle de la nourriture
c'est ce que je fais ok alors si la
planète est un océan de nourriture ce
qui est vrai c'est toute la planète qui
est couverte de nourriture que ce soit
dans l'eau sur terre dans des sphères où
que ce soit et on prend pour acquis que
tous les êtres humains savent manger
alors on prend un être humain puis on
lui pitch dans cet océan de boue fait
pire on dit mange
qu'est ce qui va arriver qui s'est pas
mangé beaucoup de personnes ne savent
pas manger et qu'est ce qui va arriver
et il va se noyer aussi mais il va se
noyer dans la nourriture alors je veux
pas vous fatiguer
et que tout c'est comment dirais-je tous
les chiffres qu'on qu'on colle surtout
des maladies qu'on a à partir de la
nourriture alors la différence qu'il ya
entre noyade dans l'océan et une noyade
dans la nourriture c'est que là la
noyade dans la danse dans la nourriture
est beaucoup plus sournoise dans l'océan
où l'on meurt tout de suite et c'est
fini basta tandis que dans la boue c'est
beaucoup plus sûr noah ça peut durer
toute la vie on va c'est une mort lente
alors on a des il ya des conséquences
sur la santé que tout le monde connaît
je mettrai pas encore là les chiffres
mais l'obésité c'est dramatique sur la
planète des maladies cardiovasculaires
on utilise toujours des formules
alarmiste est alarmante pour parler des
maladies cardiovasculaires 80 % des gens
qui meurt meurt blake a dit que la
démarche cardiovasculaire de la la ça
fait peur après ça on revient donc
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire les diètes
les régimes et tout ça alors sept
membres sournoise qu'on a dans la bouffe
c'est tout ça tout ce qu'on voit là le
diamètre cholestérol hypertension et on
nous rabâche ça à tous les jours il ya
aussi des conséquences sur
l'environnement
on va parler de la réchauffement
planétaire la pollution des nappes
phréatiques les défauts restent tout ça
autour de la bouffe on réalise pas les
conséquences de la malbouffe la famine
des catastrophes naturelles
tout ça c'est une noyade sournoise au
les gens qui font pas attention parce
qu'ils savent pas mangé où ils n'ont pas
de nourriture ils finissent par par
mourir doucement
et c'est quoi la boue et la solution
c'est le chef thémis
non ça c'était pour votre eau du c'était
pour me présenter à vous bossez chef
cuisinier et la gastronome cratie voilà
c'est quoi la gastronome classique lever
les mains pour ceux qui savent ce qu'est
la gastronome ghazi gens pas personne
c'est normal c'est moi qui les ai
inventées
alors c'était néologie j'ai créé
pourquoi la gastronome classique parce
que la gastronomie comme tel quand on
parle de gastronomie elle est trop
limitatif alors vous avez dans la
nourriture quand on prend quand je pense
que c'est ça va c'est parce que je me
suis dit à quoi sert la gastronomie si
ceux qui ont attiré nourriture mange mal
et les trois-quarts la terre meurent de
faim tout ce cheminement lait est arrivé
comment c'est que on a vu un restaurant
avec ma défunte épouse au coin de la
vallée roi sur le plateau et tous les
jours tous les jours y avait des gens
qui venaient connu au restaurant pour
avoir un bol de riz pour avoir un bol de
soupe pour avoir du pain et puis on les
nourrit c'est presque devenu un
restaurant d'itinérants entre 14h et 18h
on les nourrit si hier on s'était dit on
peut pas rester comme ça on va pas les
toujours nourrir ces gens là et puis
quand on va disparaître ils vont ils
vont arrêter de manger et c'est là que
si vous voulez l'idée de la gastronomie
gastronomes cratie aînés on s'est dit un
jour on va faire quelque chose de
durable au lieu de nourrir les gens on
va donner la canne à pêche pas le
poisson
ouais mais comment faire ça ça entre
l'idée et le faire c'était pas évident
quand on a créé la gastronome cratie
s'était d'abord on souhaite que ce soit
un mouvement c'est quoi la gastro notre
assise c'est cette approche qui est
beaucoup plus holistique comme dirait
les gens de la médecine douce par
rapport à la nutrition
et quand on prend un aliment dans la
main il faut se poser des questions faut
se dire at enseigner ça dans les écoles
qu'est ce que c'est que ce fruit qu'est
ce que c'est qu'une tomate
j'ai vu un documentaire de jamie oliver
ou était dans une classe avec beaucoup
d'enfants et puis il montré une grappe
de tomates et des enfants qu'est ce que
c'est eux et de bananes a apprécié
prenez des pommes de terre qu'est ce que
c'est
les enfants ne savez pas ce que c'est et
les fruits des légumes régulier la ccl
la pomme de terre ils l'ont veut
toujours en frites
la tomate ils ont toujours vu en ketchup
et c'est là le drame
donc il faudrait que à partir dans une
pensée gastronome crac avant de croquer
dans la tomate comme tel tu dis est ce
qu'on a enseigné où ça pousse
c'est quoi les valeurs nutritives j'ai
choisi la tomate est pas par hasard
parce que dans la tomate il ya de dennis
turpin et le ligotent pas les mots pour
la prostate
j'ai appris en faisant des questions sur
la tomate hermange d'en manger bêtement
le chef qui travaille en moi je faisais
des réductions de jus de tomate pour
obtenir ceci salé sucré acide amer
c'était que de la bouffe mais dans un
esprit beaucoup plus ouvert beaucoup
plus gastronomes crac va les questions
qu'on se pose comment ça pose qui
récoltent ça est poussée des enfants est
ce que c'est
est ce que c'est un rosier par des
pesticides est ce que les gens meurent
toutes ces questions la fecq abandonné
face à la nourriture on change de
comportement on dit je peux plus beauf
et comme je bouffais avant il faut que
je fasse de quoi alors donc on a créé
cuisiniers sans frontières très
naïvement on a créé cuisiniers sans
frontières en 2003 était l'année de nos
nos 50 ans voulait s'offrir un cadeau on
dit qu'on va créer un mouvement
cuisiniers sans frontières un mouvement
grâce trône au crac
vous avez car voilà ça sert de ces
statistiques que je montre parce que
d'un manque de nier des statistiques on
se permet à 805 millions de personnes
qui souffrent de la faim dans le monde
soit une personne sur neuf qui souffrent
et puisse à bord tout le monde était
moins à la télévision dans les radios et
tous à 10 radio web on entend parler
ok alors on s'est créé une mission
admission c'était des enfants misérable
pas les nourrir les enfants il ya déjà
des gens qui font sens très bien mieux
que nous ce soit la croix rouge ou
l'unicef
nous on veut aider ces enfants là en
donnant une formation culinaire à leurs
parents c'est beaucoup plus durable
alors en dessin on les sensibilise à
l'importance de l'environnement et puis
de la santé donc on va dans des pays ça
c'était notre rêve sur papier en iran et
dans des pays là puis si on voit des
personnes qui semble qu'ils étaient dans
la rue laver des voitures cirer des
chaussures avec des enfances d'eau on va
leur proposer s'ils veulent une job
et puis ça c'était le rêve sauf que pour
réaliser sa indique un cocon enregistré
cuisiniers sans frontières ont dit mais
ça nous prend du fric pour partir à
l'est dans ces pays avait pas d'argent
mais bon sait démerdé on a vendu des tee
shirts genre d'affaires et puis c'est
vraiment ce qu'on a fait on est
maintenant depuis 2003 en l'état on est
haut à madagascar donc mon pays
d'origine qui est un des pays les plus
pauvres de la planète on est au bénin il
ya des béninois qui ont vu ce qu'on a
fait sur notre site web
et puis il ya des haïtiens qui ont vu
qu'on risque en afrique on dit bon nous
aussi on a besoin de ça donc sonné dans
trois pays en ce moment
anja madagascar au bénin et en haïti est
là vous voyez un exemple où vous avez
vous avez sûrement entendu parler quand
il y a des comme on appelle ça là où on
envoie des enfants qui est désormais
l'un des orphelines d'accord souvent
c'est pas des vrais orphelinat ce sont
des personnes
qui ne sont pas capables de nourrir
leurs enfants puis qui vont dans un ré
qui lisent abandonne presque là dans un
orphelinat avec le coeur qui saigne
parce que c'est leur bébé c'est leur
enfant ils peuvent pas les nourrir les
laisse dans les orphelinats
alors là ce qu'on a fait en haïti est
allé chercher des personnes
on a été aidé par des gens qui ont des
enfants dans un sofa donc dans ces
orphelinats là et puis on les donne une
formation de trois mois et de cuisine et
après trois mois ils font un stage dans
un restaurant ou dans un hôtel et 80 %
75 à 80 % des gens que nous formons en
ce moment nous avons sorti deux cents
familles de la rue vont chercher dans un
enfant alors cette madame là c'est une
femme d'aller chercher sa fille et puis
à mme lalanne job elle se nourrit bien
et tout va bien alors ce qu'on se dit
voyez si on reste à la maison puis on
fait juste manger nos tomates sans
savoir qu'à du lycopène dedans bon je
pense qu'on peut faire quelque chose on
peut on ne peut pas rester chez nous en
disant oui mais c'est loin on peut pas
aider par la gastro notera si on peut
faire quelque chose
donc ce qu'on fait on va prendre des
mamans ont menacé un apprenti jardin
madagascar tout et madame là sont des
parents il y en a même une là dedans qui
m'a donné son enfant je dis non non non
on va te trouver une job tu vas avoir un
salaire peut avoir que ton enfant tu vas
pouvoir la nourrir cette dame là
aujourd'hui
elle est sous chef dans un hôtel et puis
elle vit très très très bien tout ça
pour quoi
faudrait pas que ça fait très ego de moi
de parler de ça c'est que toujours on
peut aider les gens
que ce soit par la bouffe que soit pas
comme quoi que ce soit mais la
nourriture est au centre de tout tout
tout tout que vous soyez dit savons que
vous soyez que vous croyez que vous
construisez des automobiles qui se
construisent et d d d avion si vous ne
mangez pas vous allez pas vivre il faut
bien manger n'est pas seulement que
manger faut manger intelligemment et la
gastro notre assise ces deux rangées
intelligemment c'est de susciter des
questions quand vous êtes devant une
assiette et c'est de se dire qui a fait
ça est ce que la nourriture qu'à la dent
et et équitable est-ce que les gens qui
ont cueilli
j'ai mangé est ce qu'on mange et on
était bien traité est ce que le chocolat
bon je mange c'est un drame monde sic le
chocolat c'est tellement bon on va
acheter une petite barre de chocolat de
100 grammes à 3,4 5 $ et peut-être que
dans les champs au sénégal ou ailleurs
au chocolat et et recueilli ces des
familles entières qu'ils ont payées 2
dollars pour toute la journée avec des
pesticides sur le corps et tout ça et
puis qui vont nous vendre du chocolat la
zone en plus du fonds koala lui-même il
est ni gastronomique ni sociale ni
gastronome crac
il ya déjà des compagnies de chocolat
qui m'ont offert moins de de m'aider à
me demander sur quoi que ce soit je
dirai ce que je peux aller dans les
champs pour voir comment sont traités
les gens qui ont recueilli ce chocolat
il dit renoncer à passer pas dans notre
budget en tout cas il faut se poser des
questions tout ça ça m'a amené à
l'entomophagie est ce que là la tomate
que j'ai là où la banane que je mange et
et arrosés de pesticides de fongicides
ou quoi que ce soit alors on s'est dit
il faut trouver une solution dans les
pays où nous allons
on on initie les gens à l'environnement
par exemple quand on va au marché que ce
soit bien ou à madagascar c'est
inévitable est ce qu'on va acheter les
tomates de manioc des bananes puisqu'on
la buzzer pour le court c'est toujours
dans des sachets on envoie des sachets
partout partout partout c'est dramatique
que quand vous allez à port au prince
d'avoir des sachets de plastique dans
sur les fils électriques par terre dans
les champs ou dans des parcs c'est
pareil à madagascar
c'est pareil au bénin en tout cas je
parle des pays où nous sommes allés
alors ce qu'on fait humblement pour
faire notre part pour l'environnement
on va récupérer ces sachets de plastique
là on les plis joliment on les met dans
des boîtes et puis qu'en cas une grosse
quantité en les ramène au marché pour
que les genres donne une deuxième vie
une troisième vie c'est petit mais c'est
déjà ça
et d'ailleurs rapidement là une anecdote
on fait avec magali de bol de bénévoles
de cuisiniers sans frontières
on va au stade olympique qui ont ramassé
qu'à cannes on va même fouiller dans les
poubelles pour sauver la planète et yann
a des cannes avec des cannes qu'on aura
passé on aurait pu faire quatrième ville
de poubelles dans leur seuil en cause
avait huit facteurs
donc on fait notre part et puis on
initie aussi les gens à l'environnement
autrement paris les plastiques
on récupère on fait du compost des
annales et pelures de manioc de bananes
et on fait du compost et ont fait un
jardin donc à madagascar sur un terrain
qui était super aride on a réussi à
faire pousser des tomates
parce que j'aime la tomate pas ce biais
du lycopène bon en tout cas on fait on a
laissé faire des jardins à au bénin puis
des jardins à madagascar
là où on était à port-au-prince on n'a
pas pu le faire parce qu'on était en
ville donc c'était difficile de faire un
petit jardin
alors là voilà ce qu'on fait donc on
fait on fait des faits du du compost on
récupère le plastique et on se dit si on
arrêtait parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
sauterelles à madagascar si on arrêtait
d'arroser des champs mais on allait
plutôt les chercher les insectes on
ferait quoi on éviterait d'arroser les
champs de pesticides on éviterait les
nappes phréatiques de se polluer
et puis on ferait la nourriture donc
vous savez il ya des études qui sont en
mission qui ont été publiés par la fao
là au début de l'année passée je pense
aux ondes aisée l'avenir de la planète
bas dépendent des insectes c'est très
alarmiste donc on dit quand on sera mal
pris on va manger des bibittes ça c'est
pas très vendeur
alors je me suis dit non il ya sûrement
une analogie à faire entre les insectes
qui sont des fruits du ciel et des
fruits de mer
alors là j'ai fait des tests nous tiens
j'ai regardé et j'ai lu on a dit j'ai vu
que les trois quarts de la terre mange
des insectes pas parce qu'ils sont mal
pris il mange par plaisir en afrique du
sud il ya une chenille rappelle la
chenille de mots panne qui veut dire
être bientôt la saison là quand la
chenille de mots panne et de saison la
consommation de viande traditionnels
comme le port le port la voix la baisse
dans les supermarchés tout le monde
mange la chenille de moi peindre c'est
une grosse univers tel est bonne elle
est allée à un goût particulier elle à
ces festivals chenni c'est comme la
cabane à sucre mais tout le monde mange
des bibittes et c'est bon donc voyez à
partir de là toujours dans un esprit
gastronome crac je me suis dit ok je
vais pas prendre un approche alarmiste
de la nourriture j'ai pas dire il faut
manger des insectes parce qu'on ira
depuis je habillé je veux mettre en
habits de chef là avec ma top mon tour
de caumont à bille blanche et puis je
vais défendre l'entomophagie dans les
milieux où la gastronomie c'est le foie
gras le caviar la langouste et omar et
des crevettes et ça fait son chemin
ok il faut pas percevoir
un accès comme quelque chose qui va nous
sauver la vie qu'il faut manger avec un
gone ici sinon on va mourir faut manger
les insectes un peu avec par gourmandise
et j'ai fait des tests j'ai fait des
tests avec des déchets ni de maupin où
j'ai fait des tests avec les sauterelles
avec des criquets avec des des larmes de
farine des l'art de toutes sortes de
coléoptères et c'est bon donc moi je
défends la la la la gastronomie la
consommation l'entomophagie avec ma mon
idée de de gastro lot de chef
d'abord gastronomique gastro look rate
mais pas le côté ou voilà ça va être
l'avenir de la planète il faut manger
mais de tout envoyer ça ramène à la tout
ça c'est parti de la tomate là qu'est la
tomate comment qu'on a mangé comment ne
pas la rose et de pesticides et tout ça
donc voyez en dans un esprit gastronome
kraton on mange des insectes par
gourmandise on évite les pesticides on y
parle des nappes phréatiques parce que
c'est dramatique en france en ce moment
là les gens qui travaillent dans les
dents les champs sont pointés par tout
le monde parce qu'on dit or à cause des
agriculteurs les lots n'est plus potable
c'est catastrophique
alors écoutez en conclusion je je
souhaite vous mangez intelligemment
comme les gastros nos craintes
un garçon au crac il partage il est il
milite pour la planète qui fait pas
juste manger comme un cochon il mange il
minutes pour la planète
il est en santé parce qu'il mange bien
regardez moi
et ils diffusent un bonheur alors je
souhaite à tous d'être des gastronomes
crac
et puis d'être heureux merci monsieur
davis